now that you've had a little bit of
exposure to what a convolution is I can
introduce you to the convolution theorem
or at least the convolution theorem
volution theorem where at least in the
context of there may be other
convolution theorems but we're talking
about differential equations in Laplace
transform so this is the convolution
theorem as applies to Laplace transforms
and it tells us that if I have a
function f of T f of T and I could
define its Laplace transform is let's
see the Laplace transform of F of T is
capital F of s we've done that before
and if I have another function G of T
and I take its Laplace transform that of
course is capital G of s that if we were
to convolute these two functions so if I
were to take F and I were to convolute
it with G which is going to be another
function of T and we already saw this we
saw that in the last video I convoluted
sine and cosine so let me so this is
going to be a function of T that the
Laplace transform of this thing and this
is this is the crux of the theorem the
Laplace transform of the convolution of
these two functions is equal to the
products of their Laplace transforms it
equals f of s big capital f of s times
big capital G of s now this might seem
very abstract and very you know hard to
kind of handle for you right now so
let's do an actual example and actually
even better let's do an inverse Laplace
transform using with an example and
actually let me write one more thing if
this is true then we could also do it
the other way we could also say that F
and I'll just do it all in yellow it
takes me too much time to keep switching
colors that the convolution of F and G
this is just a function of T I can just
say it's the inverse Laplace transform
it's just the inverse Laplace transform
of f of s times G of s oh I couldn't
resist it let me switch colors F of s
times G of s G of s there you go now
what what good does all of this do well
we can take inverse Laplace transforms
let me see let's just say that I had let
me write it down here let's say I gave
you the ice told you that the following
expression or function let's say H of s
let me write it this way H of s is equal
to 2 s over s squared plus 1 you know we
did this long differential equations at
the end we end up with this thing and we
have to take the inverse Laplace
transform of it so we want to figure out
the inverse Laplace transform of H of s
or the inverse Laplace transform of this
thing right there right so we want to
figure out the inverse Laplace transform
of this expression right here - s over s
squared plus 1 squared don't want to
lose that right there now can we write
this as the product of two Laplace
transforms that we do know let's try to
do it so we can rewrite this so this is
the inverse Laplace transform so let me
rewrite this expression down here so I
can rewrite 2 s 2 s over s squared plus
1 squared this is the same thing as as
let me write it this way - 2 times 1
over s squared plus 1 times times s over
s squared plus 1 right I just kind of
broke it up if you multiply the
numerators here you get 2 times 1 times
s or 2 s if you multiply the denominator
s squared plus 1 times s squared plus 1
well that's just s squared plus 1
squared so this is the same thing so if
we want to take the inverse Laplace
transform of this it's the same thing as
taking the inverse Laplace transform of
this right here now this something
should hopefully start popping out at
you if these were separate transforms if
they were on their own we know what this
is
if we call this F of s if we say this is
the Laplace transform of some function
we know what that function is this is
this piece right here I'm just doing a
little dotted line around it this is the
Laplace transform of sine of T and then
if we draw a little box around this one
right here this is the Laplace transform
of cosine of T G of s so this is the
Laplace transform of of sine of T or we
could write that this implies that f of
T is equal to sine of T all right you
should recognize that one by now and
this implies that G of T if we define
this is the Laplace transform of G this
means that G of T would is equal to
cosine cosine of T and of course when
you take the inverse Laplace transforms
you could take you could take the twos
out so you could say so now what can we
say we can now say that the the we write
it this way the inverse so let me
actually let me write this or we could
it's actually a better thing to do
instead of taking the two out so I can
leave it nice and clean we could if we
were to draw a box around this whole
thing if I were to draw a box around
this whole thing and divide divide this
whole thing is f of s defined that whole
thing is f of s then f of s is the
Laplace transform of 2 sine of T I just
wanted to include that too I didn't want
to leave that out and confuse the issue
I wanted a very pure f of s times G of s
so this is this is this expression right
here is the product of the Laplace
transform of 2 sine of T and the and the
Laplace transform of cosine of T now our
our convolution theorem told us this
right here that if we want to take the
inverse Laplace transform of the Laplace
transforms of two functions I know that
sounds very confusing but you just kind
of pattern match you say ok look this
thing that I had here I could rewrite it
as a product of two Laplace transforms I
can recognize this right here is the
Laplace transform of 2 sine of T this is
the Laplace transform of cosine of T and
we just wrote that as G of s and F of s
so if I if I have a
and written like this I can take the
inverse Laplace transform and it will be
equal to the convolution of the in of
the original functions it will be equal
to the convolution of the inverse of G
on the inverse of F let me write it this
way I could write it like this we know
that F f of T is equal to the inverse
Laplace transform of f of s and we know
that G of I should have done in a
different color but I'll do it G in
green we know that G of T is equal to
the inverse Laplace transform of G of s
right so we could rewrite the
convolution theorem as the inverse level
and this much this might maybe confuse
you more than help but I'll give my best
shot
the little inverse Laplace transform of
and I'll try to stay true to the colors
of F of s times G of s times G of s is
equal to I'm just restating this
convolution theorem right here this is
equal to the convolution of the inverse
Laplace transform of F of s so it's
equal to the convolution of the inverse
Laplace transform of F of s with with
the inverse Laplace transform of G of s
with the inverse Laplace transform of
capital G of G of s of G of s I'm not
sure if that helps you or not but if you
go back to this example it might this is
f of s this is f of s right here two
times I'll do it in the light blue this
is two over over s squared plus one
that's F of s in our example and the G
of s was s over s squared plus one and
all I got that from is I just broke this
up into two things that I recognize if I
multiply this together I get back to my
original thing that I was trying to take
the inverse Laplace transform of and so
the convolution theorem just
that okay well the inverse Laplace
transform of this is equal to the
inverse Laplace transform the inverse
Laplace transform of 2 over s squared
plus 1 convoluted with convoluted with
the inverse Laplace transform the
inverse Laplace transform of our G of s
of s over s squared plus 1 and we know
what these things are are you told them
to you but they should be somewhat
second nature now this is two times sine
of T two times sine of T the inverse
take the Laplace transform of sine of T
you get 1 over s squared plus 1 and then
you multiply it by 2 you get the 2 up
there and you're going to have to
convolute that with the inverse Laplace
transform of this thing here and we
already went over this this is cosine of
T cosine of T so our result so far our
results so far let me be very clear it's
always good to take a step back and just
think about what we're doing much less
why we're doing it but let's see the
Laplace transform the inverse Laplace
transform of this thing up in this top
left corner of 2 s over s squared plus 1
squared which before we did what we're
doing now was very hard to figure out
actually this should be a curly bracket
right here but you get the idea is equal
to this it's equal to 2 sine of T
convoluted with convoluted with cosine
cosine of T and you're like Sal either
throughout this whole process I've
already forgotten what it means to
convolute two functions so let's
convolute them and I'll just write the
definition or the definition we're using
of the convolution that F convoluted
with G it's going to be a function of T
I'll just write this shorthand is equal
to the integral from 0 to t of F of t
minus tau times G of tau D tau so 2 sine
of T conflated with cosine of T is equal
to so this is equal to let me do a
neutral color
the integral from 0 to T of 2 sine of t
minus tau times the cosine of tau D tau
D tau now if you watch the very last
video I made I actually solve this or I
solve a very similar thing to this if we
take the 2 out we get 2 times the
integral from 0 to t of sine of t minus
tau times the cosine of tau I actually
solve this in the previous video which
this right here this is a convolution of
sine of T and cosine of T it's sine of T
convoluted with cosine of T and I show
you in the previous video just watch
that video where I introduce a
convolution that this thing right here
is equal to 1/2 T sine of T now this
thing is equal to 1/2 T sine of T and
have to multiply it by 2 then we get our
big result that the Laplace transform of
2 s over s squared plus 1 squared is
equal to the convolution of 2 sine of T
with cosine of T which is just 2 times
this thing here which is 2 times 1/2
those cancel out so it equals T sine of
T so all of this mess and once you get
the hang of it you won't have to go
through all of these steps but the key
is to recognize that this could be
broken down as a products of two Laplace
transforms that you recognize this could
be broken down as a product of two
Laplace transforms we recognized this is
Laplace transform of 2 sine of T this
was a Laplace transform of cosine of T
so the inverse Laplace transform of our
original thing or original expression is
just the convolution of that with that
and if you watch the previous video we
realize that actually calculating that
convolution was no simple task but it
can be done so you actually can get an
integral form even if it can't be done
you can get your answer at least in
terms of
terms of some integral so I haven't
proven the contrary the the convolution
theorem to you just yet I'll do that in
a future video but hopefully this gave
you a little bit of a sense of how you
can use it to actually take inverse
Laplace transforms and remember the
reason why we're learning to take
inverse Laplace transforms and we have
all of these tools to do it is because
that's always that last step when you're
solving these differential equations
using your Laplace transforms